[Music]
[Applause]
I propose we call a doctor
all the best doctors are dead I can't
remember who's alive who isn't this
Comrade Stalin
I need to stop reading together the
plant how come you were unemployed at
the same time
[Music]
[Music]
everything's gonna be fine exactly fine
is it but first I know with his head
open the whole thing would have wanted
the committee as long all those in favor
Terry you animus Lee
pushed not pushed but not reached we
should you stop with this I want to make
a speech at my father's funeral no no
problem technically yes but practically
when I said no problem what I meant was
no problem
ignore me but I am very furious you're
the good guy now you locked up half the
nation yes I'm not releasing
[Music]
I've been picking out funeral cushions
with slim Hitler over there my wha
darling will be nothingness
don't worry nobody's gonna get killed I
promise you
[Music]
I have nightmares that make no sense
unless
[Music]
I will not be silent
[Music]